i want to be like a horse who's getting
like reined in
you know let's serve up some news sunny
side up
food and wine reports that the site
bonus finder is looking for someone to
travel the country's baseball stadiums
and taste test america's most delicious
hot dogs
you can apply online through tomorrow
and get
500 plus all travel baseball
and hot dog expenses paid ideal
candidates will be able to expertly
review
hot dogs based on some key criterias
ross what would your criteria be for a
hot dog not even listening to you just
think about how i have to call and sick
for the next two weeks because i got a
new career change
thanks so much jimmy are you a hot dog
fan
baseball game fan any fan i'm a hot dog
fan when i'm
at baseball games and that's about it i
can't really think of any other
occasions where i'm like
i need a hot dog when can you ask the
person you're seeing to delete
their dating app i mean how juicy is
this this is literally
modern romance absolutely and you know
what it's it's like a conversation you
have to have
i had a friend true story she was dating
somebody on one of the dating apps and
then
she it was like kind of getting serious
so she was like i'm gonna go on the
dating app and get off now
and when she logged in she saw that he
was still on and had just
updated all of his pictures with
pictures that she had taken of him
oh my god and i was like she was just
mortified i'm like well didn't you have
a conversation with him about
are we doing this now and the answer was
no
she didn't so this just comes down to
communication
a lot of layers well vice actually uh
said when can i ask the person i'm
dating to delete
tinder or you know any dating app and
they say when this question pops up in
your head maybe it's time to have that
larger conversation about defining the
relationship and it's not about
just saying no to other people but yes
to the one
that you're with entertainment tonight
reports that priyanka chopra jonas
and nick jonas have teamed up with give
india for an
urgent fundraiser and they announced the
news on instagram
please take a look at this even as the
medics learn more about the virus
the threat continues to loom over the
past few weeks
millions of indians unleashed the power
of social media to do good
and that is so inspiring i'm taking your
lead and carrying it forward
we're appealing to you all to contribute
towards the health care system which is
at a breaking point right now
so you can go to priyanka's instagram
and her instagram
directs you to giveindia.org you don't
have to donate a ton of money like every
single dollar
helps they need the help right now so
we're sending all of our love
out to everyone in india molly our first
story is about someone near and dear to
your heart
mei hillary duff's one month old baby
yo look at this yahoo life reports that
hillary brought mae to beat mandy
moore's newborn
gus and they had a blast and i know that
you and hillary of course you're your
besties from younger
and but there's an interesting story you
went to go help with baby may
and ended up staying for what like a
month a month you went to go
what is that like you she just needed
your help and you were there actually
um i what we weren't sure when she was
going to be born
may not hillary we knew that yeah and i
so i planned to go out to la for vaguely
a month
and to see when the baby came and i mean
this is her third so i really wanted to
be an extra set of hands
yeah and i'm her other daughter's
godmother so i was just
i mean i got to do bath time and bedtime
and then wake up time is the best
they're so tender in the mornings when
they wake up come on
how did it feel to hold that little tiny
baby
she is edible and she was so
so so so so cuddly too she loved to be
held
and bank banks was like that too
mashable reports that
vibes is an app feature designed to help
users get
better matches so it quizzes you on
different types of pop culture and
personality questions
to get a better feel for how you vibe
and match up to others for example
here's one are you a 20 minutes early or
a 10 minutes late kind of person
i would have to put 20 minutes early
because you know
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
oh
i'm working on it i'm working on it it's
gotten so much better this year can you
imagine how bad it used to be
i'm working on it this is great because
like you it's a way to sort of get to
know
somebody like you said more than just
like not you know
a picture and a swipe
[Music]
okay and today it's a mask that
literally blew me off way and of course
the second i saw the results
i thought i gotta bring this to the news
desk and the doggy bag
so it's mario badescu's drying mask
one of the reasons that i loved it is i
have visible pores
and there's a lot of you know
controversy they say once you got an
open pore that thing ain't ever closing
so what do you do from there this has
got
sulfur and zinc oxide and it gets to
work on that surface
and it pulls impurities from your skin
and it's got a calamine and cucumber so
it feels very
soothing but i'm telling you my pores
were
visibly gone you know who else uses this
who
ross matthews i really do i'm a master
mask kind of guy
this one is so good um all the products
on mario badescu are amazing
yeah it tightens up it's amazing no i i
am blown away i've been looking for like
a new brand of masks i want like
i want someone to take my face and just
snap it back oh i didn't know i was what
is that okay okay tightening
i want like i want to be like a horse
who's getting like reined in
you know